if you're not familiar with specs it
stands for special purpose acquisition
company here's how it works let's say
you have an up-and-coming company that
wants to go public if you wanted to do
it the right way you would have to go
through a bunch of SEC scrutiny and to
pay massive fees to Simply operate as a
public company you'll have to put out
quarterly reports host shareholder
meetings and probably deal with more
audits while this is truly quite
annoying for businesses these
regulations are what keep retail
investors at least somewhat safe but
what if there was a way to work around
this red tape well there is enter specs
specs are basically shell companies that
will go public in place of the original
company people can invest into this pack
and this pack will turn around and
invest into the original company and
given that this pack is just a shell
it's far easier and cheaper to maintain
this packet as a public company